okay so here's how you get Android
studio installed on this is Manjaro
known version should work on any
versions of Manjaro as you might know if
you've used Android studio on Linux it's
sort of a pain to install but I found it
to be really easy on here and I'll show
you you go to menu search for your
software I'd remove software and then
just do a search for IntelliJ the
company that makes Android studio and
you'll see IntelliJ IDE idea Community
Edition so go ahead and install that
I've already done it but let it install
and once it's done installing just
launch it you just do create new project
and then you choose Android and just go
ahead and you next and now what this
does when you choose Android is it
downloads all the stuff required for
IntelliJ to work just like Android
studio I've already done most of this
but just for sake of example do a quick
one so this is basically exactly what
you do and you'll be prompted to
download all the files you need to turn
this into Android studio and you can
just launch IntelliJ and do your Android
studio projects on banjaara that's it
thanks for watching see you next time